so what is coq10 good for i'm talking about
coenzyme q10 now what is a coenzyme it's something
that helps an enzyme and there's a lot of
different enzymes in the body that go way beyond
just digestion there are enzymes that help perform
many different functions there are proteins
that are involved in all the biochemical pathways
in the body for making energy to making hormones
to helping you detoxify poisonous chemicals now
coq10 is found in every single cell in your body
it's an extremely powerful antioxidant but its
main job is to stabilize membranes membranes
are outer coverings of certain things like your
cell membranes have this outer fat layer very
very important in holding the um the voltage of
the cell because it sells like a battery without
that membrane you would be able to hold the
voltage so it's it's a very key part of all cells
also the membrane around the mitochondria which
is energy factory needs coq10 to help transport
electrons through this process into atp
which is the energy currency of the body
all the lipoprotein membranes need coenzyme q10
as in hdl ldl and these are just proteins that
carry cholesterol through the body and then back
from the body back to the liver so coq10 helps
stabilize membranes especially in areas of your
body which you're generating a lot of energy okay
as in the heart the brain the kidney the liver and
your muscles so we need coenzyme q10 because if
you're generating a lot of energy you're also
generating a lot of free radical damage and
oxidation so coq10 helps to counter that now
here's the thing when someone takes a statin
they completely block coq10 and if you're going to
block this enzyme you're going to create a lot of
side effects especially muscle damage okay so if
you're on a statin you need to be taking coq10
also if you have any nutritional deficiencies
you're going to be deficient in coq10 because that
sets you up for not creating coq10 in the first
place if you have inflammatory conditions and
there's many different kinds autoimmune it's like
ms diabetes you're going to need coq10 so coq10
can help any type of heart condition it's good
for athletes that generate a lot of oxidation it's
good for people that have migraines and headaches
it's good for anyone that has chronic inflammation
if you're taking a lot of medication it's good to
take and also it's good to prevent cancer because
cancer results from a lot of damage to your dna
and so if you're taking coq10 you can actually
help prevent some of that damage hey before you
go real quick i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof your immune system it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why here's you
here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here
avoiding your environment but what about here
what about strengthening your immune system
that's what's missing this course will show
you how to bulletproof yourself and so you
can tolerate and resist your environment much
better by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description right
down below check it out and get signed up today